fueron estos legendarios solos de
guitarra tocados a una velocidad
asombrosa con control e innovación los
que catapultaron avances
fue uno de los veinte artistas más
vendidos de todos los tiempos
la banda fue introducida en el hall de
la fama del rock and roll en 2007 eddie
van halen nació en amsterdam países
bajos en una familia de músicos que
emigraron a california en 1962 10 años
después fundó la banda con su apellido
su hermano álex en la batería y david
lee roth como vocalista pronto se
convirtieron en la banda de california
que esperaba sacar a la música disco de
las listas y para potenciar su vida de
rock and roll estuvieron los cócteles de
cigarrillos alcohol y drogas duras desde
que era joven todo pasó factura en la
salud de vivan gente
tengo una cirugía de reemplazo de cadera
programada para diciembre 16 pero
depende de donde estemos en nuestro
proceso de grabación
quizás espere a enero pero no podemos
irnos de tour bueno yo puedo sentarme a
tocar no importa sabes no creo que la
gente venga a ver como me deslizo en mis
rodillas o como brinco
[Música]
luego de su cirugía de cadena en 1999 le
removieron parte de su lengua en el 2000
tras ser diagnosticado con un cáncer una
enfermedad que volvió en sus últimos
años sus tributos se han hecho para
honrar a uno de los más grandes músicos
mientras que su hijo lo describe como el
mejor papá que pudo haber tenido y dice
que los momentos que compartieron fuera
del escenario son un regalo